you've got a ranch north of LA you've
actually invited me you've been on the
show we have proof on the air you said
Conan come up to my ranch sometime and I
want to go it sounds like a lot of fun
it is fun how rural is it there it's
pretty ear you're up you're out there
like in the mountains is that right yeah
this there's some mountains on the
property it's listening now you have
mountains on the property do you have
animals what kind of I mean what kind of
wild animals are out there that's what I
would worry um let's see there's coyotes
bobcats occasional mountain lion I've
seen bear tracks Hawks wild turkeys
elephant it's not an elephant
badger that's the one I the other ones
I'm familiar with but I'm really not
familiar with a badger
what's a badger like are they cute fun
animals yeah I mean they're cut they're
probably maybe like that long about that
wide and low and they got their kind of
tan with black stripes down their back
and I don't know too much about him
either but I remember as a kid seeing
movies Lizzie that's a badger look out
for the badger which I out there Dan
yeah yeah and they're all teeth and
claws and so if you see one you stay
away have you had problems with them on
their ranch I've seen a few of them I
was uh one time one time I was on my
dirt bike I was right riding up this
hill and just out of the corner of my
eye I see a badger like run like at me
like he's attacking you know I'm on a
motorcycle what's yeah you know you got
like big heavy boots on I see him lunged
up and he's going for my leg but he
misgauged it and his face went right in
the back wheel
oh wait okay for the badges yeah they're
not so tough
what's the Badger okay I don't know no I
don't know you know I heard they're
dangerous so ya gotta go back and look
he might bite me
yeah that's it every week what a
heartwarming tale for children
everywhere Disney's gonna buy that story
from you you know we're working on
you're in the motorcycle badgering the
chain what else you have what kind of
what else what wildlife do you have like
I would be I would be lying awake at
night if I had that much wildlife around
me I'd be hearing stuff at night oh yeah
raccoons raccoons or I mean not so bad
are they well the little cute baby
raccoons yeah like the ones that were on
Carson yeah
when Johnny Carson we were growing up he
did have little baby raccoons he didn't
have a full-size recluse I mean they'd
like this right I was asleep one night
and outside the bedroom doors a sliding
glass door as a deck and there's like a
motion light and was I don't know 3:00
in the morning I couldn't sleep and I
see the light go on so I get up and I
moved the curtain and I see the back end
of this thing walked by and his was like
that high off the ground yeah I was like
what was that I go through the house and
I go to the kitchen door and there's a
little like patio outside the kitchen
and I open the door and I flipped the
light on and there's three what there's
three raccoons are two of them are big
and one of them was like really really
big and the two fairly big ones take off
and the really big one like stands up on
his hind legs and he looks at me like oh
yeah we know the raccoon yeah yeah and
he looks at me and he then he like looks
at me and he goes like this and only
then did I realize I was completely
naked
I
he's looking right at my you know yeah
my raccoon stick yeah so I was like hey
hey hey you know he's like claws teeth
he's standing up on his hind and enough
he was probably that he's right at the
right height right I'm damn it he's he's
staring at your junk yeah yeah and I was
like let me go put my pants on I'm gonna
come back but they could be you know
they get the mask on look like a bank a
guy in a mask was looking at my junk in
the middle of the night he's a pervert
all right these are wonderful tales I
love these these story his really take a
break more than that lavaca just hey
thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography